قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان غزه لم يعد
لديها اي مستشفيات تعمل في شمال القطاع
وقد تعرضت للقصف الاسرائيلي او نفذ لديها
الوقود والامدادات الطبيه نتيجه لذلك اصبح
من الصعب على مليونين ووم الف شخص يعيشون
في منطقه حرب الحصول على الرعايه الطبيه
الضروريه وقال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان
مركز الاسعافي جباليا في شمال القطاع ايضا
تحت الحصار ويتعرض لقصف متواصل ما يجعله
عديم
الفائده تعمل تسعه مرافق صحيه فقط من اصله
36 بشكل جزئي في قطاع غزه باكمله وكل هذه
المرافق في الجنوب ولا يوجد في الواقع
مستشفيات تعمل في الشمال وكان المستشفى
الاهلي وهو المستشفى الاخير ولكنه الان
يعمل بالحد الادنى وما زال يعالج المرضى
ولا يستقبل المرضى الجدد الى جانب مستشفى
الشفاء والعوده والصحابه وبالتالي لا تزال
هذه المستشفيات تؤوي ايضا الاف النازحين
قتل حتى الان اكثر من 20 الف شخص في غزه
اي ما يقرب من واح في من مجموع السكان
منظمه الصحه العالميه تدعو مره اخرى الى
وقف اطلاق النار لاسباب انسانيه وهذا
ضروري الان لتعزيز واعاده تزويد المرافق
الصحيه المتبقيه وتقديم الخدمات الطبيه
التي يحتاجها
الجرحه